نحن على الطريق الرابطه بين مدينه خرسن
وباقي الاقليم وباقي حتى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه جهود ازاله الالغام من قبل
القوات الامنيه تتواصلوا في مسعى لتطهير
هذه المنطقه وجعلها امنه امام مستخدم هذه
الطريق وسكان هذه المنطقه
الدافع الرئيسي من ازاله الالغام من
البناء التحتيه الان هو اقتراب فصل الشتاء
الجو سيكون باردا وقاسيا وبالتالي هذه
العمليه ستتيح لنا اصلاح الاعطال
الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
هي موضه
يتم تنفيذه يدويا لاننا لا نمتلك
التجهيزات المناسبه والمعدات الضروريه
والتقنيات الروبوتيه
التي تجعل اعمالنا اسرع واكثر امانا
للشرطه ولمجتمعنا ايضا
[موسيقى]
العثور على انغام ومتفجرات في طرق عبر سكك
الحديد لاعاده القطار الرابط
طبعا القوات الامنيه تمكنت من العثور عن
2000,500
متفجر ولغم طبعا كما قال ايضا المتحدث
باسم السلطات والقوات الامنيه ان هذه
المنطقه تظلم عدد كبير من المتفجرات
يتجاوز كل المتفجرات الموجوده في باقي
المناطق الاوكرانيه